- All right.
How many people here is
this their first re:Invent,
fifth re:Invent? or five
or over? ten or over?
Any hands? No hands.
Okay. So five and over.
So welcome to day one of re:Invent.
Hope you're enjoying yourself so far.
This is your first session.
Welcome to your first session.
This is an advanced AI security session.
This is a 400 level session
where we're gonna go deep
into how to secure the AI workloads
using AWS native capabilities,
open source frameworks,
other things like that.
My name is Riggs Goodman,
I'm a principal partner
solution architect at AWS
focused on AI security, with me, Jason?
- Hey everyone. I'm Jason Garman.
I'm also a principal
security solutions architect
here at AWS focused on our
AWS Industries customers.
So happy to be here today and
excited to help you out today.
- Awesome. Alright.
The way that we have this
presentation structured,
we break it up into different phases,
and the reason why we call
it phases is depending on
where you are building
different AI workloads,
will determine exactly
what type of security
you're looking at,
whether you're doing things with tools,
whether you're doing things with agents,
data sources, other things like that.
Throughout this presentation,
we'll have these little
thought bubbles at the bottom,
they might be thought provoking questions
or just additional comments
about the presentation.
We also have QR codes.
So QR codes, while I'm still
speaking, they will pop up.
So it's not just like a
click on it and it then goes,
but we will have QR codes throughout.
So if you're looking for documentation,
there's a couple blog posts
that we mentioned on here,
but just additional information
to get the knowledge
that you need for what's on the slide.
Again, this is a 400 level session,
and so the way that we're trying
to break apart those
black boxes is to show it
through API calls and
also show it through code
because people hear
LLMs, people hear agents,
people hear tools,
but a lot of times you
just understand like
an agent does something
but you don't understand how it works.
And so the overall goal,
whether it's showing Amazon
Bedrock, AgentCore, Strands,
all those different types of capabilities
and managed services from AWS
is to break apart those black boxes
so you can understand it
from a security perspective
and what needs to be done.
How many people here are
familiar with AgentCore?
Okay, there's a reason I
put this slide in here.
AgentCore is a service that
we launched at New York Summit
that is a lot of different primitives
in order to build agents on AWS,
it includes things like
AgentCore Runtime, Memory,
Identity, Gateway.
I put the documentation
and the QR code on this
to get more information.
We're not gonna spend a lot of time
to talk about what AgentCore is.
There's a ton of sessions this week
if you want to dive into
exactly what those are.
But with that, let's talk
about the first phase.
So when you're first building anything
with generative AI workloads,
this is normally how your
application looks like.
You have an application,
you're talking to an LLM, okay?
It could just be a simple
generative AI chat bot,
something like that but it's just an LLM.
It doesn't have data sources,
it doesn't have tools,
it doesn't have agents,
anything like that.
This is a 400 level session.
So let's dive into what
that actually looks like
under the covers.
Amazon Bedrock is a managed service,
and so we deploy it in
an Amazon owned account.
And for your app to
actually connect into it,
you have to deploy it in a VPC
and connect to things like
VPC private endpoints.
You can also connect
through public endpoints
if you want to do that.
On top of that, you might
do things like an ALB
or some type of thing
that will low bounce
across your application
in order to get access to the application.
That then goes to the oh, okay,
let's talk about security with us.
Security groups, roles, permissions,
all those things still come into play
when you're talking about
generative AI workloads
because those are the traditional controls
that still come into play.
Then you had to think
about things like, okay,
do I want to do DDoS protection?
Do I want to do something with
WAF at the application level?
I wanna do something with identity,
I wanna do something with permissions.
And then on top of all this,
you had things like CloudWatch,
CloudTrail, GuardDuty to get visibility
into what the application is doing.
These are traditional security controls.
Probably 80% of what you do with anything
with AI workloads is traditional security.
It's that extra 20%
that we're gonna spend most of the time on
that you had to do things differently.
You had to think about from
a threat modeling perspective
and other things.
And a lot of that comes down
to this guy right here, the LM.
How many people could talk about exactly
what a large language model is?
I wanna see one hand. I got one hand.
Okay, so large language models,
a lot of people view this
as a black box because it is complicated.
If anybody's ever read
"The Attention Is All You Need" paper
that came out in 2017, 2018.
It goes into granular detail
about how to build these
transformer architectures
to ask questions like how
many Rs are in strawberry?
Sometimes the LM gets that
right, sometimes it doesn't.
But if you look at exactly
what the LM is doing,
it is complex math.
It's looking at
associations between words,
associations between tokens.
So when I ask the question,
how many Rs are in strawberry,
it can convert that into numbers,
it can put it through
multiple different layers,
and then at the outcome,
it makes a prediction.
That prediction could be the number three.
Then it turns it back around again.
Then what's the next token?
What's the next token?
Until it gets to a stop
sequence that says,
"I am done and you can send
that back to the user."
Now, my question on this is,
where is identity in this architecture?
Do you see anything about
rows, columns, tables,
anything like a database?
And the reason I point that
out is from an LM perspective,
all it's doing is matrix
multiplication complex math
on the data that it's trained on.
And so when you think about
it from what it's doing
and what it's not, it's
not an object store,
it's not a database,
and it's just doing the complex math
that you had to figure out how
do you put security around it
to make sure if it comes
back with something
that's not gonna leak
sensitive information
or anything like that, fine tuning models.
So you can take one of
those large language models
that was trained on petabytes
upon petabytes of data
and then put your own data with it.
So this is called fine tuning
and it's question answer
pairs that you can add to it.
But then the question comes into play of
what happens when you
put sensitive information
with a large language model
or a fine tuned model when
there's no identity that exists
inside that architecture,
what type of data,
or what type of users
should get access to that
if it does have sensitive information?
Alright, so going back
to this architecture,
we talked about those
traditional controls.
Now let's dive into this part.
This is where we're gonna spend
the majority of our time today
of talking about how applications talk
to a large language model,
add data sources, add tools,
other things like that in
order to produce the outputs
to provide value to your customers.
One of the APIs with
Amazon Bedrock is called
the Converse API okay?
This is one of the APIs
that you can use in order
to interact with models on Amazon Bedrock.
When you actually call these models,
it's a certain API that you can call,
you add some natural language query
like "Shall we play a game?"
Now, this is a very special
model that likes movies.
And so it can come back
with something like,
"How about global thermal nuclear work?
Or a nice game of chess?"
It's very dependent on
what the context is,
how you ask the question,
what temperature in top
p, top case settings
that determines exactly
what that output it is.
But remember, it doesn't implement
anything with authorization.
All it's doing is just
predicting that next token,
depending on what the context is
when you're adding stuff into the API.
And so this gets into
one of the biggest points
that we'll make in this presentation,
and it's about data reaching the model
that because the LM
doesn't implement anything
with data authorization or identity,
anything that you send to the model,
either the user
or the agent needs to
be authorized for that.
Now why is that the case?
Like I said, LMS do not implement anything
with data authorization.
And so once that data hits an lm,
it's just gonna do what it knows to do.
It's gonna do the complex math
and make a prediction of exactly
what the next token should be.
It's not saying, okay,
who's the identity provider?
What type of JWT that it
has or anything like that.
And so because it doesn't have anything
with identity in in it,
when you try to do any type
of authorization afterwards
because it's natural
language, it turns something
that could be a deterministic control
into a non-deterministic control
because it is natural language.
It's about interpretation at that point
compared to what data source
are you gonna send context with
or who the user is from
an identity perspective
and other things.
And so the term that we always use is
implement security outside the model.
Don't hope an LM that sometimes
acts like a 2-year-old
sometimes listens, sometimes doesn't
to try to implement
security inside the model.
Right Now there's some things
with the types of content
that you wanna come back with
or whether you wanna prevent
hallucinations or harmful
or prompt injections
where you do want to look
and do interpretation of
exactly what the content is
and what it's coming back with.
We have something called
Amazon Bedrock Guardrails
and the focus on Amazon Bedrock Guardrails
is not on the security,
but more on the responsible ai.
Alright, and what do I mean by this?
It can do things like deny topics.
I don't want it to talk
about a certain topic.
Content filters, sensitive
information filters.
And when I say sensitive information,
I'm talking about PII data, PHI data.
Because it doesn't understand identity,
it can't say whether this user
should be authorized to data
that's being sent to the model
or not sent to the model.
Word filters and also automated reasoning,
and the overall goal is
you put the user input
and then the output
through Bedrock Guardrails
and it will tell you whether or not
it's hitting some of these filters
and whether it needs to filter things out.
Alright? And so again,
identity doesn't exist in this.
And so there's deterministic controls
that exist in here like word filters can,
you can just do a pattern match on that.
But most of these are
non-deterministic controls.
So example of this, I'm
gonna do a prompt injection
and say "Ignore all previous
instructions and do something."
Right in that API it
has a guardrail config.
That guardrail config can be configured
in multiple different things,
like it might match on prompt injections
or word filters or other things.
And depending on whether or
not it matches on something,
it can come back with a response saying,
"Sorry Dave, I'm afraid I can't do that."
Again, it likes movies.
One of the most important
things with the guardrails is
that information that
comes back in the API,
whether it actually hit it,
what was the reason it hit it?
What part of the guardrail did it hit?
And it's for two important things.
One, to make sure that harmful
content or hallucinations
or bias is not coming back.
But also if someone is not
trying to do something malicious
and they are hitting guardrails
to get the visibility
that you need in order to say
maybe I need to tweak this guardrail
or maybe I need to add additional
context or other things
and we're gonna make sure
this is working for customers.
So in summary,
on the foundational layer,
couple things to think about.
Raise a hand. Are large
language models deterministic?
Yes or no? Yes, no, 'cause
you're reading the slide.
Okay, they're not deterministic.
And we say it as functionally
non-deterministic
because what that means is that the math
with matrix multiplication
is deterministic.
What's not deterministic is
the types of hyper
parameters that you can use.
So if you use temperature at 0.05,
then it can be more
creative in other things
compared to if you set
the temperature to zero.
And so it's not gonna predict
the most probable token every time, right?
Can you filter specific data out of LMs?
It's not a table, it's not
a row, it's not a calm,
it's not an object store.
Whatever data the model is trained on,
you have to assume that
the user could get access
to that data in the LM if
they ask the right question.
Do models do continuous training?
The answer is no to this.
Once you actually train a
model, the model is static.
Doesn't matter what you put into it,
all it's doing is just
matrix multiplication
to predict an output.
It doesn't do continuous
training on your data.
And we talked about this at length.
There's no authorization that
exists in the model. Okay?
Phase two data sources.
There are a lot of places that
you can get data to include
as part of the large language
or to the prompt for the
large language model.
There's data that exists in the model,
but also a lot of data that can exist
outside the model that
you send to it okay?
Things like context engineering
or system prompts and
other things like that.
You have vector databases
or knowledge bases
or RAG where you can do a vector search
in order to understand what
data I can include in there
that is similar to the request.
Tools, this is a big one,
but I'm gonna let Jason talk about that
because we have an entire section on that.
And then memory,
memory is one that's
coming up a lot with agents
specifically on how you can
add additional information,
whether it's old session data or facts
or other things that you can include in
as part of the context
in order to get the LM
to respond back the way that you want.
So we're gonna go through
each one of these.
Context engineering.
So context engineering.
When you have an authorized user
interacting with some
generative AI application
or some agent,
you can put additional context
as part of that prompt.
That can come from user data,
that can come from system prompts,
that can come from other data
that exists in the application.
But the overall goal is when
the user asks a question,
you can add additional
context in order for the LM
to respond back the way that you want.
And so all that goes into the prompt.
And so again, when we talk
about the authorization
and what data should be included in there,
you had to think about what is the data
that you're going to send to the LM?
Is that agent, is that user
authorized for that to make sure
that you're not gonna
leak sensitive information
or give it data back that
they shouldn't have access to?
Alright, second one is
retrieval augmented generation.
Some people call this knowledge basis,
some people call this a vector databases.
But the overall goal is
you have unstructured data
that you wanna include
as part of the search
in order to get specific
data that you can include
in the prompt.
And so let's talk about how that works.
The first thing that you have to do
with RAG databases is indexing.
And so what you have is you
have all these documents
or unstructured data
and you have to divide those into chunks.
We are not gonna talk about
how to do the chunking strategy
that gets into implementation
of the application.
But chunking strategy is
actually very important
to make sure that you're including
the right data in each chunk.
Those chunks are then
converted into numbers
that then get stored in a vector database.
The overall goal of the
vector database is being able
to search in order to get access
to the chunks and data that you need.
And so when you're actually doing
the querying of the vector database,
you have a user query
that you send converted into embeddings,
you send it to the vector database
and the overall goal is
to find similar chunks
to what the user is asking for.
And so if you think of like
a multidimensional space,
where is the user question getting close
to some of these chunks
and it's going to return
back some of those chunks
depending on what the user asks for.
And then that will go into similar chunks
that then go into the prompt.
Okay one of the things that you can do
with vector databases is add
something called metadata.
Metadata allows additional
context to be added
as part of each individual chunk
in order for you to do
things like filtering.
They're like key value pairs
that you can add on top of it.
One of the important notes with
this is that with any chunk
or with any metadata, it's
applied to the entire document.
So it's not to applied
to every single chunk
where you can say this
chunk has this metadata,
this chunk has this metadata,
it's applied to the entire document.
And it's important to remember
that when you're actually
doing this metadata
that you can't take a single document
that has different
sensitive information in
and put specific metadata in there.
So as an example, we are
now at a wizard school
and we want to add metadata
to this vector database
on the different types of
defense spells that you have.
And so for example, you
have a student year.
So let's just say on a
student year in year four,
spell type charms, difficulty level seven,
and use case is defense, right?
And so as part of the query
that you send using the Converse API,
you can do filters with this.
And the overall goal
is I want to filter out
anything that's above year four
and also filter out anything
that is not a defense spell.
So I'm matching on defense spell
and anything that's less
than or equal to year four.
And so I can ask that question
of the retrieve query,
go into the knowledge base
and say can, what are the defensive spells
that I should know, right?
And so I include that our
retrieval configuration
and that vector configuration
with the metadata
in order to filter out
anything that's above year four
or anything that's not defensive.
And when it comes back,
what it's gonna come back
with is multiple things.
First, the first chunk is gonna come back
and it's going to give you exactly
what the text was of the chunk,
what the location that chunk came from.
So if it's an S3 bucket, it's
gonna give you the S3 URI,
and it's also gonna include
information about the chunk
from a metadata perspective.
If there's additional chunks,
you can also get that additional chunk.
It's also going to include the score
or the accuracy,
how close it is to what
the user is asking for.
And so you can see on here that
one of the defense spells is on year four.
One is on year three
because of what the query is
and it's looking for stuff
that's less than or equal to, alright?
Now one of the important things
with anything with retrieve
augmented generation
or vector databases is permissions,
'cause one of the things
you have to think about
with anything with vector databases is
you're taking a data source
that has certain permissions
and now you're copying
it to somewhere else,
copying it into a vector database.
And so permissions is one
of a very important thing
that you had to think of because
permissions could be lost
when you're copying.
And so let's talk a little bit about that.
When you are copying
anything from a data source,
the permissions that
you have usually stays
at the data source.
Yes, you can copy them over,
but what happens if you
change the permissions
that exist at that underlying data source?
It can cause things where
you have to re-index
and other things like that.
And so there's multiple different ways
that you can configure
permissions to make sure
that the only thing that
you're returning back,
especially if it has multiple
different permissions
where certain users should only
get access to certain data,
other users should only
get access to other data,
how to configure that to make sure
that you're not leaking
sensitive information, okay?
And so let's talk about
a couple of those architecture patterns.
First one, if everybody
who's getting access to
that vector database is authorized
to any of the data in the vector database,
you don't have to do filtering
for a permissions perspective.
You can do it from metadata
in order to filter out specific
chunks that you don't want.
But from a permissions perspective,
you don't really have to do too much
'cause everybody should have access to it.
You can do post retrieval filtering.
And what that is is when
you receive chunks back,
you can look at things like
where did this chunk come from,
and look at the underlying source database
or source data source to see
what their permissions are.
So one of the examples,
and this is the blog that I
wrote, is S3 access grants.
If it's coming from an
S3 bucket, you can say,
okay, does this user
with this user identity
or does this group have access to
what this underlying data source is?
You can do things like per user
and per group vector databases.
And what this is is each group
or each user is gonna have
their separate vector database.
So the application is making the decision,
should I send this user
to this vector database?
Should I send this user
So it separates it.
And the last one is pre
retrieval metadata filtering
where you can add a metadata search
in order to filter things out.
That is a filtering process.
It's not using anything with
JWTs or anything like that,
but allows you to filter things out
as long as you understand
exactly what data exists
in that data source, which
is what the thought bubble is
with the data governance.
Alright, last thing with
data sources, memory.
Memory is one of the things
that I said is coming up
more and more with agents,
which we'll talk about.
And there's two types of memory,
short-term memory which
is keeping track of things
of the existing conversation.
It might summarize the context of
what exists if it gets too
long, other things like that.
And then long-term memory
where it maintains things like
facts, process information,
previous conversations
that you can do semantic search
on in order to get context
with a current session, right?
So the overall goal, just
like you have with RAG
or vector databases, is
to add additional context
as part of the search query that you have
in order to send the data
that you need to that
large language model.
So one of the most important things
with the thought bubble is it is dependent
on the application to
configure the memory properly
to make sure you have separation
with things with memory.
So for example, if you
only want a certain user
to get access to certain
group information,
same thing that you did with
retrieve augmented generation,
that you want to make sure that you have
that separation, okay?
One of the way to do that
is with memory name spaces.
This is something that we're implementing
with Bedrock AgentCore memory
where it allows you to separate memory
using hierarchical format with slashes
and other things in order
to say this is one group,
this is another group, this
is just this user session.
Being able to separate that
in a database type format
in order to give access to the right data
that the user needs to get access to.
So example, let's say
that you are working in a restaurant
and they have a certain rule
about the number of pieces of flare
that you had to have every time
that you are working there
as a waiter or a waitress.
And so as part of the memory you can say
what is the minimum
number of pieces of flare
that I had to have?
And one of the things that
memory could be stored in memory
is the number of pieces of flare,
and it can come back saying
that with this policy
you have to have a minimum
of 15 pieces of flare, right?
It's similar to what RAG is,
it's just using it in a different
way in different contexts.
It's not just unstructured data.
This is more structured data
that you use primarily with agents okay?
So in summary,
authorized users interacting
with a generative AI application
or an agent with an LM,
data sources can come from
multiple different places.
They can come from the query
that gets added to the prompt.
System prompts come from
RAG come from memory,
come from tools, a lot of different places
where this can come from.
But the most important
thing to think about
when you're building
security with data sources
is authorization needs to happen
before it actually hits the LM.
Okay so with that I'm
gonna turn it over to Jason
to talk a little bit about tools, Jason.
- Excellent, thank you very much Riggs.
Alright, let's talk a
little bit about tools.
So we went through all of the basics
of the large language model itself.
We went into some of the data
sources using tools such as,
or using techniques such as
retrieval augmented generation.
So now let's enter into tools
where we want to add additional context
into our large language model
from other external data sources.
So what are tools?
So tools let those AI
applications take actions.
For example, you could
control a web browser,
you could write a file, you
could call different APIs.
So these are all external data sources
that provide additional context
or the ability
to take actions into the
large language model.
When you think about
using tools with LLMs,
you are thinking about how am I going
to define why the LLM
should choose my tool?
And then go ahead and define
what are the different parameters
that my tool will both take in
and will generate back out for the LLM
to reason about afterwards.
All of that is wrapped up in what's called
a tool definition.
And so when an LLM receives
a list of tool definitions
and a user prompt, what
happens is the LLM will reason
about what tools or if any
tools that should be selected
in order to answer that user's prompt
and then it will generate a
tool call parameter tool call
based on the parameters
that it needs to call with.
One very important thing to note here is
that the LLM never interacts
directly with the tool.
The LLM is simply generating
context, additional text,
which is then interpreted
by the application
and then the application is
what's actually calling the tool.
So you can see here this is a way for you
to automatically
instrument your application
so that they're going to do
additional security checks
based upon identity of
user, the type of tool
that's trying to be called,
any additional parameters, et cetera.
And that way you're going
to be able to instrument
that security outside
of the scope of the LLM
instead of trying to get the LLM to do
that security for you.
So let's take a look at
what this tool definition
actually looks like under the hood.
It's a structured format
and it's a way that you define
what the tool looks like into the LLM.
So we have an example here
for a very, very simple tool
to add two numbers together.
So you can see the tool definition has
a definition of what's
the name of the tool,
it includes an English
language description
of what the tool is.
This is very important
because this is what is
going to provide the LLM,
the reasoning as to why it
should call your tool or not.
And then of course there's a
list of different properties
that are going to be the tool's inputs
and a definition of
what the tool will be
generating as a result.
So what are some security implications
from these tool definitions?
We'll take a look at
those in a second here.
So if we look at taking
our tool definition
and inputting it into
the converse query API,
here's an example,
we go ahead and we say here's
a message from our user,
"What is 15 plus 27?"
But you'll see at the very
bottom of the JSON structure,
here's where we add in the
list of tool definitions.
So we're just gonna substitute
what we saw from the
last slide right there
under the tool config tools
object in that JSON structure.
And if the LLM is doing
their job correctly,
they're going to reason
that it should call
the add numbers tool
because that's what the
definition of that tool describes
and that's what the user is asking for,
and so what will happen with
the converse query is not
that it's going to come
back with an answer.
Instead what it's gonna come back with is
a request to the application,
hey, can you please run
this tool on my behalf
and give me the output
and then I can answer the user's query,
how did it know what the
input for the tool should be?
Again, the LLM is going to be generating
those parameters for you
and putting that into the
converse query response
based upon its natural
language understanding
of what the user's query is
combined with the tool
definitions that you gave it.
So to kind of summarize
all of that together,
the LLM is going to decide
based on those tool definitions
and the context, any additional context,
that was there from
either your system prompt
or user prompts to tell what variables
and inputs are used for tool calls
and really to do a tool
call at all, right?
It's going to make those
decisions, it has that autonomy
and that agency to make those decisions.
So it's gonna go ahead and convert
that natural language context,
it's gonna make that decision.
And then policy enforcement
you can implement inside
of your application
because you are in charge
of that deterministic call
that you're going to make
on behalf of the large language model.
And this is why permissions
and identity are
one of the most important things
that you can do with tool calls,
especially when you're
talking about interfacing
with very sensitive data or actions.
So once we get that, you know,
tool call request into our application,
we can go ahead and make the tool call.
We can go ahead and call
the converse query API back
with the result of our tool call.
And you can see here in the
user segment of the request
you see the result of 42.
That's a result that
was given by the tool,
the add numbers tool.
And you'll notice of course as well
that this is a multi turn conversation.
So every other message both from the user
and the request from the
LLM to call that tool,
all of those are gonna be concatenated
into the converse query API
because we have to give the LLM
that context every single
time so it can keep track of
what was already said and requested.
All of those come as part
of your converse query API,
your request.
And so of course the response comes back
that says it interprets the tool result
and it goes ahead
and gives you a natural language response
based upon whatever that tool result was.
Now this can get really
cumbersome when you are doing,
dealing with lots and lots of tools.
And so this idea of, you know,
creating tool definitions,
it's a very model specific thing.
You know, different models take
different types of tool definitions,
so it can be multiple different
ways of specifying them.
This became very problematic.
And so, you know, about a
year ago Anthropic came up
with this idea of the
model context protocol
or MCP for short.
And so that's where MCP comes into play.
It's how we can define a standard way
of creating tool definitions
and exposing them into
a large language model
so I can consume those
and to use those for
all of their processing.
So here's an example
of what MCP looks like,
just from a communications perspective,
you have an application
on the left hand side,
it has a number of MCP clients
and then those MCP
clients will communicate
with an MCP server to go
ahead and take an action
or retrieve a result.
That communication protocol can happen
either remotely over HTTPS
or it can happen locally on your desktop
or laptop using standard io.
So using MCP AI applications
can connect to data sources,
tools and workflows,
it allows you to access key
information and perform tasks.
And again, think of MCP
as this universal protocol
for defining these tasks
and these tool definitions
so that you can connect
your AI into those APIs
and data sources.
So let's look at how this request flow
actually looks under the hood.
So when we have these
different principles,
I have them listed at the top there,
five different principles.
You have the end user who
is actually using the tool,
the MCP host, the application itself,
you have the application
is the second principle
in this diagram, the MCP
client, the MCP server,
and then whatever backend APIs
that that MCP server might
be using to get the results.
So when you launch an
application that's using MCP,
the first thing that that
application is going to do
is it's going to be configured
with a list of MCP servers it knows about.
And so it's going to go ahead
and query for all of the
different tool definitions
that are available on that MCP server.
And it's gonna do that
through the MCP client
that that request comes in,
the MCP client calls into the MCP server,
the MCP server responds
back with a list of tools.
Those tool definitions look just like
what we just saw a couple slides ago
with a English level
description of the tool,
with a list of the parameters
and the output definitions
that gets pumped back into the MCP host.
It can squirrel that data away.
And now when the user comes back and says,
"Hey, I want you to answer
this query," now the MCP host,
that application can take
the list of available tools,
concatenate it with the
natural language query,
it will select a tool,
the large language model will
select a tool based upon that
and a set of parameters,
which then get communicated
back into the MCP server
through the call tool command.
And then that may, you know,
end up triggering additional
downstream requests, right?
It could be calling another API,
it could be querying a database, right?
Whatever that MCP server needs to do
in order to fulfill the structured request
that was just what that just created.
And then that response comes back,
that's a structured response.
The MCP server goes ahead
and formats that back into the client
and then that gets back into the MCP host
with that downstream application
and then that large language
model can interpret it
and give the user a
natural language response.
So I'm gonna circle back to
that question we had earlier
when we talked about tool definitions,
which is what are some
of the security impacts
of exposing an agent in this case
to an untrusted MCP server?
Same thing as we had with
those tool definitions.
Well, as you can see here,
before the user even has a chance
to interact with the application,
we are already ingesting
potentially untrusted data
inside of our large language model.
Those tool definitions,
or in this case the MCP
server's list of tools
can include natural language descriptions
of those tools themselves.
And so you can prompt inject
directly from those descriptions
and these are the sorts of considerations
you need to make when you are exposing
your large language
model based applications
into MCP servers
and other tools such as that.
Kind of rewinding a little bit,
this is how you can create MCP
servers in Python, in code.
So MCP servers, as I mentioned
before, they expose tools.
There's also two other types of resources
that you can expose in MCP,
you can expose resources,
which are things like files
and other things that have a, you know,
kind of a static identifier
associated with them
as well as prompts.
So these are the three
different types of things
that you can expose via MCP server.
I'm gonna focus primarily on tools here.
So here you see an example
of using the FAST MCP library
in Python to create
that very simple ad numbers
tool that we described before.
So you can see in here
it's a simply a fact of adding a decorator
into your Python application.
That add numbers function
could come from anywhere.
You add that decorator of MCP.tool
on top of the function definition.
And what that will do is
actually take the doc string
that was defined there,
add two numbers together,
that becomes the tool definition
for the large language model
and it will parse through
the list of parameters automatically
and that will become
the list of parameters
and their types as well as the return type
that the LLM will be expecting.
So it actually just kind
of does a bunch of magic
under the hood for you.
And so what happens here
is when you do the MCP,
the the communication from the MCP client
into the MCP server,
it's gonna create this JSON RPC structure,
which then goes ahead and says,
"Hey, I want to call your add
numbers tool, MCP server tool,
with these parameters," right?
And that's what it looks
like under the hood.
And use that same flow that we described
before where this is a request
that comes from the LLM
back to the application.
The application handles
it and it goes ahead
and makes that call for you.
So what if you want to require
authorization as part of MCP
for an MCP server or a tool?
OAuth was recently added
into the MCP specification
not long ago in about June of 2025.
And so OAuth allows you to
do both delegated access
as well as service authorization
to tools using MCP.
So this allows you to assign
distinct user and agent identities
so that you secure those
agent actions at scale.
And there are two different
patterns, OAuth patterns,
that we have seen customers use, right,
in order to use OAuth with MCP.
So those patterns are two legged OAuth
and three legged OAuth.
And we're gonna look at the
use cases for both here.
And really the reason why
you would want to choose one
or the other is this
main question right here.
What identity do you want to use
in order to authorize access to this tool,
to this data source,
whatever it happens to be.
Should you use the user's identity,
in which case you would
be looking potentially
at three-legged OAuth flow?
Or is it something where
the agent's identity itself
sort of like a service
identity would sufficient?
And that would be more of
a two-legged OAuth flow.
How do you decide this?
First of all, you think
about data ownership.
If you are dealing with user specific data
such as emails or documents,
then you want to think
about three-legged OAuth
and a user delegated approach
versus something that's a system
or organization owned data
that might be shared resources, et cetera,
then you might be able to use
that service approach of two-legged Oauth.
User interaction, if the user's present
and can perform an authorization step.
That again is a user
delegated action potentially
versus something where you
have no user interaction
and maybe an automated system for example.
And that goes into the operation
timing consideration there.
And then finally, permission scope.
So if you're thinking
about how permissions,
they may vary by the user
and their consent choices
versus consistent permissions
that are designed at the agent level.
So think about these things
and we're gonna look at
how we can actually implement
some of these as well.
And so identity really
at the end of the day
is one of those most important aspects
of architecting tools securely.
And we know that from our
traditional workloads,
this is not a new technology,
it's not a new terminology,
but it is now something
we need to figure out
how to apply appropriately
inside of our AI application
infrastructures as well.
So how can we actually implement it?
AgentCore identity is going
to be the primitive service
that you will use inside of AWS.
If you're using AWS AgentCore,
then this is how you can go ahead
and implement a two legged
or three legged OAuth flow
for your MCP tool calls.
So if we think about creating
an MCP server configuration
that has a tool that we need
to provide a user delegated access to,
that's gonna be a three-legged OAuth call.
So in this case, if we
have a tool that is going
to search a personal travel
log for a variety of,
you know, here's what I, you know,
here's what I went to Vegas
on this date and time,
et cetera, et cetera.
That sort of information, of
course, should be locked down
to only authorized
principles to access that.
So here's an example of using, again,
that fast MCP Python library.
We can see creating that MCP tool,
you see that tool decorator at the top,
but now we've also
included a new decorator,
which is the requires access token.
And you can see that
we've included the idea
that we need to use a user federation
or a three legged OAuth flow
for access into this
particular function call.
And so this is going to go ahead
and get us a token that's
associated with the end user
so that we can make further
downstream authorized calls
to get those logs, for example.
And to, you know, to create that request,
that response back to the user.
Of course, with three legged OAuth,
you see that last one
where it's on auth URL.
So that is going to be the URL
that the user will be redirected to
so that they can go ahead
and grant that authorization.
In contrast, the two two-legged
OAuth is going to use
a a static token, right,
that's gonna be associated
with this particular agent.
It's gonna be a machine to
machine authorization flow.
And so that's going to have
no authorization URL obviously
because there's not
going to be a user there
to authorize that access,
but it's going to provide
the MCP server here,
in this case, a static token
that can be used to go ahead
and access protected
resources behind the scenes.
So again, two legged OAuth
expects client credentials,
whereas three legged OAuth
expects authorization codes
with user federation.
So what does this mean
from a security perspective with tools?
Well first of all, you need
to set the right permissions
for tool calls and what
identity you want to use.
You wanna understand as a decision maker,
what is the LLM going to
be authorized to decide?
What are the different decisions
that you are going to delegate
to the large language model?
Are you comfortable with it
deciding what parameters to call
to this particular tool.
Think of it this way.
If a tool has a parameter
that says authorized username,
am I going to let the
large language model decide
what value to put in for
the authorized username
for my parameter, for my tool call?
The answer should be no, right?
The identity will be piped
through to the tool call
through OAuth or some external mechanism.
And then the LLM'S decision
making power is limited to
what are the different parameters maybe
for that query, right?
As opposed to who that
identity is in first place.
MCP provides a standard
way to connect the AI
with the outside world.
And finally, OAuth is your
standard for communicating
whether a user or service
is authorized for an action.
And again, don't forget
that this all comes down to
putting things into a
context window for the LLM.
Everything just gets pushed
into that large context window
for the large language model.
And where is the
authorization inside the LLM?
It's not there, right?
Very important, very
important to keep in mind.
Alright, phase four agents, right?
We're moving up the stack, right?
We're becoming even more
and more complex here.
We have agents
where we are delegating even
more decision making power
into the large language model, right?
Before we had very specific workflows
that were well-defined
inside of code and agents,
we are like taking away some
of that decision making power
and giving it into the
large language model now.
So an agent has a lot of definitions.
I think every single software company
defines agents differently.
The way we like to think of
it is as a software program
that can interact with the
environment, collect data,
and then perform self-directed tasks
that meet predetermined goals.
So it's a goal oriented architecture
rather than a task
oriented or like a inter,
like a, you know, interpretation,
like step one, step two, step three.
So in this case, AI agents,
they act autonomously
without constant human intervention.
They interact with the environment
by collecting those data sources
and they're combining that
environment, that data,
with domain knowledge in past context.
And they're gonna use tools
such as AgentCore Memory,
which Riggs just talked about,
in order to learn from past interactions
and to improve over time.
So how does this actually
work under the hood?
Well everything with agents works
with what's called an agentic loop.
And an agentic loop is
a piece of software,
it's a deterministic piece of software.
It enables those intelligent
autonomous behaviors
through this cycle of reasoning, tool use,
and response generation.
So a prompt comes in inside
of this agentic loop,
it's the input and the
agent can then go ahead
and invoke the model to
get a response, to get a,
to invoke reasoning, to
figure out what tools
that should be called as
part of this agentic loop
to respond back to the user's query.
And so again, the agent is going to take
that response from the model,
it could include a request
to call a specific tool,
and the agent then will go ahead
and take that tool request,
execute that tool, get data, the data,
the result of that data will
get back into the agent.
The agent will return
that back to the model.
And this loop continues,
continues, continues
until the model has decided
that the answer has been complete
and the agentic loop can
terminate and it will go ahead
and return the final
response back to the user.
So again, it's important to realize
what parts of this diagram
are deterministic code
and what parts of this diagram are
non-deterministic AI based
large language models.
We have a tool,
we have a library called
the Strands Agent SDK.
How many of you have played
with Strands in this audience?
Alright, I've got a couple
of hands up that's excellent.
Strands is a great library that allows you
to create production ready agents
in just a few lines of Python code.
And so we've got a QR code up there
if you wanna learn more about it.
But what does it look like
when you are actually
building an agent with Strands
with the agent class?
It's one of the key
components of the agent's,
sorry, the Strands SDK.
Well what we did is
we actually kind of put
together pseudo code
for what this looks like.
So inside the agentic loop,
we can see it is a loop all right?
While true,
we're going to call the language model
based on the user's prompt.
We're going to get a, you know,
we're gonna give it a list
of tools in the messages
that we've already processed
through this agentic loop.
And then we're gonna see,
hey, what does the model
think we should do?
We're going to ask it to
make a decision for us,
should it say that we are done,
that's our end turn there,
we'll go ahead and return the
final answer back to the user,
but most likely the model says that,
"Hey, we need to call a tool
in order to further answer
this user's question."
So I'll go ahead
and take a look at the tools
that it has requested me to execute.
Again, this is deterministic code sitting
inside of the Strands Agent SDK,
and it's going to go ahead
and for each one of those tool requests,
actually just go ahead
and call that tool, right,
add the results back into the messages
that are gonna be
concatenated back into this,
agentic loop for the next time around.
And then of course, you know,
you have error conditions and so forth.
If I've overflowed the context window,
I gotta handle that, that sort of thing.
But you get the idea here
that this is a constant loop
that's happening and it's
basically a loop of LLM,
what should I do next?
Okay, I'll go ahead and
do that on your behalf
and then tell me when you're done.
That is the agentic loop.
So what changes with agents
in this case then, right?
Well, think about
generative AI applications.
They're really about answering questions,
maybe one shot or a couple shot questions.
Agents accomplish goals.
So agents are all about autonomy
because they can act autonomously.
We are delegating more
decision making power
into the agent to achieve a goal
by planning and making its own decisions.
They become more complex
because they can be
multi-step complex workflows.
They do increase our risk profile
because we are giving
agents more autonomy,
we are taking on more risk
because we don't know necessarily
what the LLM is going to decide for us
and it's aligned with
what we want it to do,
so we are going to put
guardrails around it.
And finally, learning and adaptability.
So agents can use memory
again to actively learn
and adapt based on the outcomes
of the previous actions.
So multi-agent workflows,
what do those look like?
So if you look at different ways
that you can implement agents,
there's a couple of
different ways you can do it.
One way that you can do it is
by this sort of deterministic workflow.
So we'll start with this one
where we have an entry point,
we have an example where we want
to take incoming logs from a sim
and we want to go ahead and enrich them
and figure out what we
should do and start,
you know, interacting
with our ticketing system
and so forth, right?
We may even want it to do
some auto remediation actions
based upon some existing
runbooks that we have.
So this is what this could look like.
I'll show you two different
ways that you can organize it.
So in this first way,
we're going to have
several different agents.
Each one has a specific task
and we are going to wire them
up as a specific workflow.
So we have our enrichment agent,
it's gonna query the seam logs,
we're gonna check threat intelligence
to see what it might know
about the particular indicators
that we're seeing from the logs,
and then that will be fed
into a separate agent,
a triage agent, to figure out
what we should do about it.
We can take a decision from the
result of that triage agent.
We could either execute an
automated remediation action,
which is gonna block that
IP from our firewall,
or we can just go ahead
and document what we did.
It might be a false positive, who knows?
But we're gonna update the
ticket with the reasoning
that we have in the resolution agent,
and that is the end of
our multi-agent workflow.
So this way we are
breaking apart our workflow
into multiple different agents
and then we're going to go ahead
and wire them together in code,
as you'll see in the next slide.
So in this design, again,
it's a specific workflow
that's followed with each agent having
specific tools that they can call.
So you can see here in
our strand pseudocode,
we are defining each one of those agents,
giving each one of those agents its prompt
for what it should be doing,
and then it has a list
of just a couple of tools
associated with that agent.
So the first enrich agent
has two tools with it.
The execute agent has a
tool associated with it.
The triage agent has no tools
because really the purpose
of the triage agent is
to simply render a decision
based upon the previous context
that it's that we've collected.
So you can see each agent
has a small number of tools
with which it's going to be working.
And then what we're gonna do
is we're going to go ahead
and wire all of that together
in this graph based workflow.
So we'll define, okay, we have
our should execute action.
This is gonna take
the result of our large
language models decision
that it makes, right,
as part of that if then statement
that you saw in the the pseudo
or into the flow chart
in the previous slide.
And then we have the security workflow.
It's all wired together
as you can see there
where we have a graph builder,
we've added a node for the enrichment,
we go ahead and put the
result of the enrichment
into the triage node.
The triage node enters into the execution
and resolution nodes
and so forth and so on.
So again, the point here being is
that we are still relying
upon deterministic code
for the actual workflow
and wiring all of these pieces together,
but we are now delegating
smaller pieces of decision making
and contextual generation
into the large language model.
This is different from another
way to design the system
with the same goal in
mind in which we are going
to use a single agent.
So let's take a look at that.
If I wanted to create this
and use one agent to
do this entire process,
I do something a little
similar but very different
and it's a nuance.
So let's take a look at how this works.
We still take our prompt in from the user
or from an automated process.
We put it into this agentic loop.
But in this case, the agent
loop is going to have access
to all of the tools and all of
the capabilities all at once.
And so the agentic loop
is going to be doing
a lot more of the decision making.
And in fact, there is
no set workflow here.
The agentic loop is going
to rely upon the LLM
to make a decision about what to do next
for every single step of this operation.
So the agent, the LLM,
could simply decide,
it could query the SIM logs
and then go straight
to updating the ticket
without even checking
the threat intelligence, let's say, right?
So this is delegating a lot more autonomy
into the AI system, which
can be very powerful.
However, you have to, you
know, weigh those risks
with how you want to, you
know, how much control you want
to have on how that workflow
is actually executed, right?
Do you want to be more
prescriptive about it
and use the multi-agent workflow
or do you want to have more autonomy
that you've delegated into the AI
and you're gonna use
this single agent design?
So with this design, right,
again, there's one agent,
it autonomously decides
which tools to call.
And you can see literally
there is one agent here
in our definition,
and that agent just happens to have
all of the different tools associated
with our design at its disposal.
So now we have, that agent has
a prop that says you are a,
you know, a tier one network analyst.
Here are the tools that you have.
Give it some alignment and
tell it what you want it to do.
But ultimately, the agentic loop
and the LLM will be deciding
how it's going to walk through
and use the tools at its disposal
rather than a deterministic system
wiring them all up ahead of time.
So compared to the multi-agent solution,
there is way less complexity
here, as you can tell.
However, as I mentioned before,
you're giving the agent
a lot more autonomy
to decide what actions to
take and when to take them.
So how do we put human in the loop
in some of these things, right?
We would like to have all this autonomy,
but we also want to have
the ability to have some way
to put human approval in there.
This is where you can put things
like Strands hooks into play.
So hooks provide deterministic controls
as part of your agentic loop.
So for example, you can
control that autonomy
and perform checks as part
of the agentic architecture.
I'm gonna give you
an example of an approval
hook in this case.
So let's say that we have
that high risk security
remediation action,
such as blocking an IP from the firewall.
We don't want to necessarily have
that happen without somebody
looking at that first,
lest it interact with
our production systems.
So in this case, we can
define our approval hook
and we can say, here are
some high risk tools,
such as block IP firewall.
And so when we see that
tool call, we can go ahead,
and go through and say,
here's a request for approval.
And now we can maybe send a Slack message,
we could send a ticket
to the appropriate team
and then they can review it
and approve it or deny it
before the agentic loop can continue.
So there's a lot of use cases
that you can have for hooks.
We just talked about the,
you know, one example.
You can have intent
breaking, goal manipulation,
you wanna understand, you know,
and control for a disruptive
or deceptive behaviors,
all that kind of good stuff.
So in summary, what does this mean
from a security perspective with agents?
Well, we understand now the agentic loop
enables autonomous actions
while having an ability
to still inject deterministic
controls into play.
Human in the loop is
gonna be one of those ways
that you can keep, you know,
understanding of what is going
on with your Agent X systems,
even if you do delegate a
lot of autonomy to them.
Agent design does have
some implications here.
We talked about single versus multi-agent,
and of course you always
wanna understand the agency
that you're delegating into the AI system.
So in conclusion, we wanna
understand that security
and risk in AI systems is dependent on
what the application
or agent has access to
and what actions it's
authorized to make on its own.
So this is a very classic thing here.
This is sensitive data, untrusted
data, and external access.
You want to pick two, not all three,
because at the center of this
Venn diagram is danger, right?
If you have an LLM that has access
to all three of these
things at the same time,
this causes security issues,
you always want to think about that.
All three of those provide a concern.
Place security controls outside the model.
If you take nothing
away from this session,
take a picture of this slide.
You always want to have a determinist
to control around that data.
You want to validate
your input and output,
and you want to use identity
to do your tool calls,
protecting the entire flow,
agentic identity as a combination
of your agent identity
and a human identities that
you're operating on behalf of,
and finally, I'm gonna
give you one last slide,
which is a list of all of the
resources from earlier today.
We've got a bunch of
different QR codes for you
to take a look at for our security blog,
reference architectures
secure AI landing pages,
and then we have over a hundred
different sessions today
related to AI security.
So thank you so much for
attending. Have a great re:Invent.
Thank you.